we start today with a tornado that
caused severe damage in northeastern
Pennsylvania last night the storm that
ripped through the Scranton area was so
powerful it overturned cars ripped up
trees and sent debris flying through the
air at least six people were hurt here a
gas leak is now threatening the area
this morning and emergency crews are
warning people to stay away Don Dahler
is at a shopping center in wilkes-barre
Township that was torn apart by this
storm Don good morning good morning I
don't know if you can hear it but
there's a loud hissing sound coming from
over here and authorities aren't sure if
that's escaping compressed air or a
natural gas leak so they're keeping us
pretty far away from the scene but even
from this far away you can clearly see
that an army of bulldozers couldn't have
done as good a job of destruction we
have roofs that have been thrown down
onto the parking lot in the street here
and across the street at that car
dealership you see cars flipped over
lots of damage there a little further on
there is a u-haul building right in
front a u-haul truck has been tossed on
top of another one now the National
Weather Service is sending some experts
here shortly to see whether it was a
tornado in fact they touched down here
but the folks who saw this storm in
effect have very little doubt Township
officials say the destruction stretches
for about a mile
thousands of people lost power when
winds up to 50 miles an hour
whipped around debris and brought down
trees and powerlines now no homes
fortunately were destroyed the storm
shattered windows at the shopping center
and scattered debris across the parking
lot the area is still considered an
active emergency because of that gas
leak that propane gas leak we mentioned
that's inside one of these stores an
employee at Panera Restaurant reportedly
saw tables and chairs flying through the
windows the winds were so strong that
they tossed cars from the parking lot of
that car dealership and u-haul trucks
lifted from the ground and slammed into
nearby buildings emergency officials say
actually everyone was really fortunate
that this happened overnight because of
this had happened during the height of
the business day
undoubtedly they would had many many
more injuries Nora that's an excellent
point Don thank you so much